[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment hey guys the
third episode of the final season titled
the long night was the longest Game of
Thrones episode although the long night
itself turned out not to be that long
compared to the last one it lasted for
generations it was one hell of an
episode and before we do break down on
episode 4 preview let's firstly review
season 8 episode 3 the episode begins
the preparations being underway with the
army of the Dead just outside the walls
and the tension heavy among the living
the first 10 minutes of the episode are
sumptuously slow bill to the army of the
deaths attack the Lord said gets the
first line of the night when Sam saddles
up next time looking terrified it makes
you arias comment about the same being
there on the battlefield knowing fully
well he should be down in the crypts
because all he would accomplish in this
battle is giving hard time to others
defending him yet himself died
protecting him er had to save him as
well and David John had to make a stop
to help Sam on his way to the cot so to
protect brain from the night king all
Sam was during this battle is liability
anyways back to it a writer emerges from
the darkness and we're all expecting
something terrible but no it's
Melisandre she's back as expected in the
season 6 finale Melisandre said to John
I can help you win this war when trying
to convince him not to banish her from
the north and here she is coming to
their aid in the last moment no Sasha
touches the array of other Trekkie rider
this is a few magic words in valerian
any lights on fire and then the Iraq's
of every single person in the Trekkie
cavalry are set ablaze which is
personally my favorite shot of the whole
episode still there's something that I
don't quite get about all of this during
first two episodes of NFL is preparing
for battle arming everyone with
journalists and here they are
the Dothraki building ordinary wrecks
let me remind you that only Valyrian
steel journalist and fire can be used to
kill White's
what was the plan for the tracking mass
suicide redirects not even building
suitable weapons I mean he was still a
suicide attack with the flaming racks
but at least they now
weapon that could actually be used to
kill the army of the Dead before
Melisandre right was it really their
plan for the Trekkie to fight against
the nine king's army with weapons that
cannot even kill them
thank the Lord of Light man Sanjay
arrived in the last moment to at least
give to the track a proper weapon to
fight in a king's army the first charge
is ready to fight the dark that was is
not so pleased to see her they have
unfinished business an account of
torching Shireen Baratheon but most on
she manages to convince him to spare for
a little longer
there's no need to execute mr. dowlas
I'll be dead before the dawn no Sandra
then gives a long look to the unexpected
hear of this episode Arya Stark and here
we could already tell her is going to
have a great role to play in this battle
the Dothraki cavalry led by Jiraiya in
the company with ghost charged into the
void and attacked the army of the Dead
flaming Iraq's held high and the
unsullied catapulting fiery balls of
pitch pass then we watch from a distance
as the flaming Iraq swirl and slash and
then go out slowly but surely until
almost none remain and the few spare the
track is linked back to the castle juris
ride and we are left wondering if ghosts
made it however season 8 episode 4
preview gave an answer to that question
he's alive and well ghost lives I'm
still disappointed Amira and her pack of
wolves did not come to help the Starks
during this battle Danny and Jon watched
this from a nearby hill vigil in a regal
meeting for tonight King to come for
brain in the godswood watching her army
get slaughtered
Danny abandons the plan quickly and Jon
has little choice but to follow her into
the air
Jaime saves her brain from a gruesome
death at White hints just before Danny
comes in which you're going to save them
all for a moment oh hey girl John scopes
out the situation and spots the row of
white walkers nearby he is getting good
at handling his mount but walkers used
the cover of snow to confuse Jon in
midair on the walls of an flr hotel
since that'll go down to the Crypt
as she sees the barrel is getting ugly
but since that doesn't want to at first
saying she'll not abandon her people
Arya convinces her to go down an arm
serving us blade since the cell she
doesn't know how to use it and Arya
tells her to stick them with the pointy
end the same thing John said to Arya in
the second episode of the very first
season that's a nice little callback in
the gut so brain awaits his destiny with
Ian car
well George Amy Bryant or moon ginjuries
found and others make their way through
the undead in the thick of it Sam is
nearly killed by a white but the Lord
said saves him his relief can only last
for a moment as his old night's watch
friend is skilled just then by a white
then we have an emotional conversation
between brain and Fiona in the godswood
Ian apologizes for the things he's done
but brain cuts him off and says
everything you did brought you barrier
now where you belong home just as I
predicted but unfortunately that wasn't
the only prediction recurring theme that
came true next we see brain working into
a few Ravens and spying on the night
king in the crypt Sansa finds a group of
scared women and children accompanied by
Tyrion outside the fog of war is so bad
that John and Danny actually scrape each
other as they fly by on their dragons on
the ground living or wisely falling back
to Winterfell as the dead continued to
dominate the battlefield they are solid
hold the dead back as the rest of the
Living retreats Yarmuth data tells the
trench poles where they can
well Arya pixel whites with her fiery
arrows saving the Hound our choice to
use our flaming arrows to lie the
trenches but the cold prevents her from
doing so Dany was supposed to do it with
her dragon but the folk of war is so
thick that that was waving his torches
cannot get her intention great worm is
quick to solve this problem escorting
out now Sandra to the front line so she
can light a trench and fire the count
cannot handle the fire he retreats from
it as we have already known he would
from the trailer he's terrified and in
fear of all the fire around him when FL
is on fire
there are flaming swords around him and
flaming arrows flying all around however
just as I predicted his script overcome
his fear to help a Starkie trouble in
the crypts Tyrion argues in favor of
going above to help after all he might
be able to using his mind if we were
there we could see something that others
do not something that makes a difference
he tell stories who doubts it tyrion
points on the Battle of the Blackwater
and how he was the one who saved King's
Landing the day which he did as beside
it being his plan to use wildfire on
Stannis's fleet he also saw a secret
passage to which they could attack
Stannis from behind which they did and
which brought a victory very sick
knowledge is that but also points out
that he almost died a day as well
Tirion admits but still he made a huge
difference it's an ongoing conversation
I do somehow believe that if Tyrion had
been outside it might have made a
difference not just because as he said
himself you'll be surprised what I do to
avoid joining the army of the Dead there
is no organization less suitable for my
talents but because Tyrion really did
make a big difference back at means
laning and defending it so he maybe
could have made a few bad moves out
there as well
sensor says they all would be useless
out there and most heroic thing they
could do now is look the truth in the
face Tyrion in sales also spoke about
their marriage which Senza finds hard to
ever work because of the German Queen
and his divided loyalties missandei says
without the German Queen there will be
no problems we would already be dead and
I have to agree with me saying they on
this one if not for the track he didn't
sell it and most importantly her two
dragons stable tall died at Winterfell
back to the battle the trench did buy
them some time but eventually the whites
laid down on it and form bridges
rendering the barriers useless the
whites quickly stormed walls and now the
battle truly begins there is no retreat
from here watching ng panic seeing the
white scroll up the wall made us all
think he might die there but we were
quick to be reminded he's the son of
Robert Baratheon who's one of the best
warriors in his time as he kills White's
Jaime and Brienne fight at each other's
backs Seminoles dies again but your
saves him Arya kills a bunch of whites
but soon enough even she is not able to
fight him off due to their numbers and
all she can do it at point is try to
survive sink her in trouble the Hound
finally jumps back into the fight the
battle does not go well as the iron of
the dead quickly wins the wall same
breaches his gates this is something I
have been expecting it doesn't come as a
surprise at all the night King had
multiple giants in his army and John
only needed one to get inside Winterfell
in the Battle of the bastards although
what I did not expect is for it to go
straight for Lee in a moment the white
giant knocks aside several men killing
them and the injuring Liana
however Leonids of house moment and here
she stands and has no intentions of
running away
she fiercely runs toward the giant who
scoops Rob and crushes her but then I
met her last breath she kills Evita
journalist
extra time they both fall to the ground
dead the battle is in the skies now
vissarion attacking his siblings and
their riders they're holding their own
for now down there are a sneaky makes
the way through the Winterfell library
avoiding White's along the way she makes
it out alive but the tension in that
scene and the long run from the library
was horrific
Barry can the founder searching for Arya
to the calls of NFL and they find her
are they saved
but barracks less life is lost when he
takes several wounds whilst protecting
Arya they managed to get him away but
just long enough to bring him to a room
where male Sanjay's we learned by barek
was brought back to life by the Lord of
Light so many times his destiny was to
save Arya Stark
so she collator step the knight King
with the pointy end no sanchez says the
Lord of Light brought him back for a
purpose and now that purpose has been
served which is a null sangeun Arya
reunite and experimental Sanjay's
prophecy is coming to play she told our
bacon season 3 that she would see her
again and that she was shot many eyes
brown eyes green eyes and blue eyes
arias quick to figure out which eyes
she's not shot yet the blue eyes and she
knows her purpose she realizes Barry had
to die for her so she could shut those
blue wines the night Kings eyes and then
she leaves the room with a clear mission
outside riding on this area of the
knocking blessed are calling the men of
our walls but before he can land John
and regal attack him and he finally get
two Germans fighting seeing Jon Snow and
Rey go against the night king in this
area and reminded me of the battle above
the gods I which was an aerial duel that
took place in the skies above Harrenhal
and gods eye between two of the most
powerful dragons veigar incorrect cysts
and the riders prince Aemon Targaryen
and priest daemon targaryen
during the civil war called the dance of
the dragons caraxes slammed into veigar
locking jaw so makers neck just like the
night kings and john strangles did to
each other
Reiko swing is also tore which we can
tell from the episode for preview at the
last moment Danny swoops in on Shogun
and knocks the night king from his area
jack hits the ground with regal but soon
so does the night king expose for Danny
to take her shot
dracarys but fire cannot kill him which
doesn't come as a surprise to me as it
might writers I already talked about it
in my videos
already so tonight King walking through
Dragon Fire in season seven anyways
faced with the treat of losing another
dragon to the night king Danny and jokin
retreat Jamaica run for the night King
on foot but night king doesn't want to
take his chances against John he raises
all those who have fallen every
unsullied every Dothraki every Norman
soldier every Knight of the Vale a
reviling
as predicted human races the long dead
Starks from their tones down in the
crypts in episode two oils mentioned way
too many times other crypts are the
safest place to be for them to actually
be safe it's a total massacre the only
thing I don't quite understand is why
there was lonely in a star core recently
seized Rickon stark white because they
said those star corpses that came to
life are hundreds of years old
so how come there was none of these
characters among them well anyway then
the night King just walks away and
leaves his minions to take on John brain
was indeed his target all along but he
wanted to wait until the forces of NFL
were completely overcome before heading
to the godswood and taking his shot back
outside the castle walls John is facing
down a huge amount of whites but he said
when then he comes to his rescue burns a
path for him to reach Winterfell and
help bran she also answer dragon for no
apparent reason Deir Ezzor Geoghan is
being attacked by White's down to the
point where Danny's afoot and about to
be killed venture comes to his Queen's
aid the Jerome flies off to say himself
while Joey and Danny fight for their
lives it was so strange to see Denny
wield a sword but she did pretty good
job once got admit just lashes way
taking more heads and some deep ones as
he defends the him with Sharon lands in
the centre of Minerva and starts burning
it with his blue flame as John runs to
the courtyard of NFL to get to the night
king everyone fights their best from
John himself
Jamie brilliant Podrick same thing on to
Joey and Danny as the night King arrives
in the godswood brain returns to himself
to see the end of theone who is the last
man standing between him and night king
thean Brent says you're a good man thank
you they scene definitely made most of
us tear up but feeling is relieved he
charges the deny king where a journalist
Piron dies but he dies a hero Theon's
whole story was going this way and as
expected he died protecting brain he
saved his sister he
came back to Winterfell to defend his
home in the Starks he fully redeemed
himself his story was bound to end here
the night King is on brain approaching
him as he did the other three eyed Raven
just when it seems it'll end the same
way
a leaping assassin jumps on the night
Kingdom the night King turns to catcher
but denarii odd jobs curve Oliver and
still dagger into the other hand just
like she did in season seven when
sparring with Brienne a names low for
his heart the place where the journalist
penetrated so long ago to create a night
King so basically the dagger used to
start the war between humans since it's
the one is now used in season 8 and the
one with the undead I suppose brain knew
what was going to happen all along
that's why he gave her the dagger and
they reunited
he knew Arya would save him and all
humanity at the last moment and as the
night King shatters every white Walker
shatters along into ice and every white
chops as well his Aryans flame dies and
he's gone
Winterfell at Winterfell as much as many
people love this scene there are just as
many people hating on it saying that it
doesn't make any sense how are you could
sneak up on the night king like that
especially because he was accompanied
with old White Walkers I actually don't
have a problem with Arya killing the
night king but it was a bit
underwhelming that the long night lasted
this short and the tall the building up
to the night King and his unstoppable
army of the Dead was stopped in his
first major battle in fact in my opinion
makes sense that Arya sneaked up on the
night king without being noticed by him
or his wife Walkers because it was
foreshadow to happen remember in the
season premiere evangeline Arya reunited
general standing exactly where the night
king was and estaría how did you sneak
up on me it's not like Arya has insane
stealth skills sold sudden she's had it
all along and sneaking up a noticed on
the night king was definitely foreshadow
to happen some of you might ask but why
was John even resurrected when he did
not play any major part in this battle
or how can our Abid want to kill the
night king when he was supposed to be
him the prince that was promised the one
is born of line of the Mad King well
cool said it's got to be him to kill the
night king remember the prophecy said
the prince was promised will bring the
dawn not necessarily kill the leader of
the White Walkers Jon still is the
prince that was promised in my opinion
and in mind the area who delivered the
final blow
but it's John who brought
Don John was erected for purpose just
like barrack was if John had stayed
there the Starks probably would not have
got a man or fell back without John
Danny does not go to nor to help
and even if since I can manage to get
Winterfell without John her forces would
have been crushed by the night king and
all of them would have died we thought
John Aria doesn't go home and doesn't
kill the night king because remember she
went to Winterfell after hearing that
John is the king in the north or is the
one who killed a night king but in my
opinion is Jon Snow the prince was
promised who brought the dawn that's why
the Lord of Light brought him back to
life in season six and he served his
purpose that's just my opinion
after the debtor defeated it standing by
Danny drops to his knees he protected
his queen and now he can die tonight as
Jorah dies Danny weeps for her protector
who has been with her for very long
jørgen curls himself around Danny to
make her feel better his death marks the
end of house moment here they stood and
the north will remember him survivors
turned castle stand in shock of what has
happened her destiny fulfillment Sanchez
rides out of the gates of NFL and his
cards her cloak and necklace her true
form revealed she collapses into dust
before the Sun rises the end of episode
3 episode 4 will be amazing and one
cannot wait to see it
it'll be a build up episode 4 the last
word that comes in episode 5 stay tuned
for the episode 4 preview breakdown and
as always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace